[Musique]
c'est traditionnellement à villèle que
s'est déroulé le grand vent décembre du
conseil départemental afin de célébrer
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
un travail de mémoire est important pour
le président cyrille melchior il nous
convient de commémorer cet événement en
hommage à tous ces esclaves qui ont été
libérés ces personnes qui ont été
libérées à travers cette loi de 1848 et
cette liberté bien évidemment doit se
construire sont recherchées
continuellement et le département encore
une fois mais participe à cet effort de
mémoire bonne fête kaf à tous les
réunionnais quel que soit l'endroit où
ça at-il et à la réunion où ailleurs
bonne fête kaf azote ses amis
réunionnais
les festivités ont débuté à la chapelle
pointue avec la séquence symbolique et
solennelle de l'enlèvement de leurs
chaînes aux esclaves suivi de chants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cortège s'est ensuite rendu au camp
ma roue puis s'est déroulé le
fleurissement du mémorial
on a su aussi faire passer
génération en génération
notre histoire
on avance
chaque jour
vers la lumière
et avec aussi une force de transmission
de notre patrimoine
qu'est-ce que ça qui est important c'est
que on maîtrise notre histoire en
prenait soin pour tirer toutes les
valeurs
de ce qu'a connu nos ancêtres et fonds
puisse être encore plus fort pour
affronter l'avenir
le musée de villèle deviendra bientôt le
musée de l'habitation et de l' esclavage
l étage de l'ancienne maison des maîtres
se dévoile la maquette du projet aura un
grand bâtiment d'accueil il rappelle
dans ce jeu emblématique du morin
élan vers le ciel on retrouve dans la
structure
la suite on a toute une visite hazard
qui permet
vers sept grands
un très important du projet où
l'histoire d' esclavage d'être
ok tu un point de transition
monde de l'usiné
[Musique]
a su on va avoir des passerelles pour ce
banal
dans les
cette longère permet
des esclaves en allant vers
[Musique]
permettant aux visiteurs d'avoir une
complète pour ce futur musée de
l'habitation
et de l'est
avec de l'eau
[Applaudissements]
et pédagogique ouh la la culture créole
va pouvoir être enseignée partager il ya
deux
la soirée s'est achevée par un grand
kabar connectés
[Musique]